мене зва гарнага Кирило я ученик 10 класу
Лідер команди речники майбутнього зараз
ми знаходимо в цьому
Катюжанка Ми дуже так добре щільненько
волонт допомагає скронею плюс дого Стася
якось покращити еколог збирає пластик
пресу
його наша команда сформувалася дуже
хаотично Але це все Була активна молодь
зі своїми напрямками
в'я ж до уявлення іде ми вірші що Це
буде допомога в Це Це буде
волонтерство зараз ми друку рз Дета Я
потребують наш
вко покоління победи це мабуть те що
навколо мене це люди я мене оточують Це
моя команда це мо друз це мо знай
абсолютно нд нд нд
небайдужою на победу якось допомагаю
тримаючи
вму